good morning Hank it's Saturday you
actually can't get this shirt at pizz
miss.com because it's from last year
just a reminder that everything at pizz
miss.com disappears at the end of pizz
Miss but that's not why I'm here today
Hank so listen in the long history of
pizza miss one thing I've definitely
never done is make an extra pizz Miss
video but I'm making an exception today
because I have an extraordinary update
you may remember that a few months ago
nerd fighteria joined a long-standing
campaign to try to convince the
pharmaceutical company Johnson and
Johnson to relinquish secondary patents
on their life-saving critically
important drug resistant tuberculosis
medication bedine the patent was
scheduled to expire but Johnson and
Johnson was using kind of a backup
patent to extend their Monopoly for a
further four years and lots of people
were like well well that's not great
like people in low and middle- inome
countries need access to Boline and if
there were generic competition we know
the price would drop by more than 50%
and we need that now and after a few
days of pretty intense pressure from
nerd Feria and others Johnson and
Johnson along with the global fund
announced that there would be generic
competition but only in some countries
many countries including Ukraine and
South Africa and tons of others were
left out of that deal and so it always
felt like a little bit of a win but a
compromise win but then today Johnson
and Johnson announced that they will not
in any way enforce their secondary
patents on bedak
in any of the 143 low and middle inome
countries in this world this is the
announcement that we have been waiting
for and that I have to confess that I
despite my ridiculous over-the-top
optimism about all this stuff never
thought was possible like people in nerd
Feria along with lots of other people
have continued to push Johnson and
Johnson over the last month and say you
should really just release the secondary
patents on bacine entirely and I've
always been like well well I mean that's
that's probably not going to happen but
it just happened so huge credit to
Johnson and Johnson I mean they really
showed that they care about patient
access in a major way yes they did it
under tons and tons of pressure
including like pressure from governments
like the South African government but
still they did it they have essentially
agreed to everything that Doctors
Without Borders and Partners in Health
and treatment Action Group and so many
other people have been asking for I
realized that we've had like a string of
these victories so it's worth pointing
out like how wildly uncommon it is for a
pharmaceutical or Diagnostics company to
agree Under Pressure to lower prices and
these are massive wins we're talking
about tens of millions of dollars that
will be saved by the global fund and by
low and middle inome countries around
the world that can go into treating more
people for tuberculosis Johnson and
Johnson thank you for giving me just a a
wondrous pizz Miss gift and also it's
perfect timing because this year here
all our profits from pizz Miss go to
support better tuberculosis care in the
developing world so wow I mean I'm
genuinely trying to explain what a big
deal this is but I can't because it's
such a big deal that it goes way beyond
my capacity for language thank you to
everybody who wrote an email or made a
phone call or wrote a tweet or made a
meme you have made a huge difference and
Johnson and Johnson thank you honestly I
feel nothing but gratitude right now I
mean a little bit of surprise but also
so a lot of gratitude Sarah's out of
town but I'm going to go like drink some
champagne by myself to celebrate cuz
that's how great this is okay dftba Hank
I'll see you on Monday